Britain's new king is 73 years old
taking on a role he's been preparing for
to accept for most of his life in recent
years Charles had assumed many of the
Queen's duties but actually taking the
role of Monarch is still a huge
transition let's bring in CBS News Royal
contributor Julian Payne who used to be
the head of communications for then
Prince Charles good morning to you
Julian thanks for joining us I first
want to start off by acknowledging
um you know the queen was very young
when she took the throne and now we have
her son who's in his 70s we know about
his beliefs his personal feelings how do
you think that will impact the monarchy
you're absolutely right this is a very
different situation now we have somebody
who is taking the throne exceeding the
throne at 73 years old now there is no
way of getting around it he is not in
the first flush of Youth but what we
will see instead of that is more than 50
years of experience on the world stage
he met Winston Churchill he met every
prime minister since then every world
leader and that experience is something
that he will be able to bring to his
British prime minister but also the
other leaders of the Realms and the
Commonwealth around the world so really
we're seeing an exchange of Youth to one
of experience
Julie and I like I like your wording
there the first flush of Youth I'm going
to be using that but you know him very
well and the perception is that he has
wanted to be king for a very long time I
want to know a is that true number two
number two is it a Bittersweet time for
him because if he has wanted to be king
for a very long time on the other hand
he's also lost his mother who he
affectionately called mummy how do you
think he's feeling what do you think
he's thinking today
I think that this is undoubtedly a
moment of real personal sadness for King
Charles III now what's a comfort I think
in a strange way is he has a duty to
perform and in many ways this is the
reality of the situation many people
have said over the years that this is
this is a role he's been desperately
trying to get hold of the reality is
I've talked to him about it I know his
attitude and it is simply this it is a
role that he was ready to take on when
the time came he like his mother takes
the view that this is about Duty and
service you do your duty you provide the
service to the nation when you're asked
to do it you don't seek it out you don't
try and get hold of it but when it comes
to you you take on that role and you do
it to the best of your ability so as we
stand here today I think he will have
private moments of reflection when like
any son who's lost his mother he's going
to be terribly sad but at the same time
he's got to begin his new rain so he's
going to address your nation later today
what do you expect to hear from him
that's right I fully expect him to begin
by praising his mother and her Legacy
and saying what that means to both him
personally and us as a nation then I
think he'll talk about the days ahead
and what what he hopes to do as a
servant of the people don't forget the
last time the queen signed off a
national address she signed it off as
your servant and I know that's very much
the approach that he has so I expect a
little bit of that in there as well
yeah Duty actually means something in
the UK and they follow that very
strictly thank you very much Julian
Payne I know we will talk again